[MUSIC PLAYING]
SAPTARSHI MUKHERJEE: I
am Saptarshi Mukherjee.
I head the product marketing
function for our data analytics
business.
And today I have the privilege
to be joined by David Narayan,
and David is a distinguished
engineer from Home Depot, one
of our iconic
BigQuery customers,
and then Vivek Yadav, and
Vivek is a customer engineering
lead for Google Cloud.
And today we're going to talk
to you about how enterprises
are reimagining what's
possible with a data warehouse
and how they're
essentially going
beyond the conventional use
cases of operational reporting
and BI against
BigQuery and building
some of the things
that are incredible.
Like, for example,
Home Depot built
a planet-scale application and
network log monitoring system
for their organization.
So before we get into
the Home Depot story,
why are we trying
to reimagine what's
possible with data warehouse?
And why data warehouse
is in the epicenter
of all this conversation?
If you look at
fundamentally what
has happened over the course
of the last few years,
enterprises are experiencing an
astronomical growth with data.
And Home Depot last
year talked about,
how did they move from their
traditional data warehouse
system to BigQuery to handle
scale and have more agility?
And that is true for
many organizations,
because traditional
data warehouses were not
designed for this amount
of data explosion.
And the other thing is,
when enterprises are not
able to ingest, store, process
that large amount of data
not only coming from
traditional sources like ERP
or CRM system versus sources
like web clicks or IoT sensors
or application log, et cetera,
then they are essentially
creating a lot of data
silos and they're not
able to get the most
out of their data.
And this is a stat from
"Harvard Business Review."
It says, enterprises today
typically analyze less than 1%
of unstructured data and less
than 50% of structured data.
And we are trying
to change that.
Why data warehouse?
Because data management
and data analytics
is just not confined to
a warehousing platform.
This is from Gartner.
They are one of the leading
industrial analysts in the data
management space.
They say, fundamentally,
data warehouses
are still the foundation of a
company's analytic strategy.
I started my career as a
data warehousing engineer
before I became a marketer.
And I remember the days when
we used to kind of essentially
create very specific
operational reports
on a specific set of
dimensions and facts
for our business users.
World has evolved a lot.
And we kind of
swung the other way
to start thinking
about data lakes
are going to be the
ultimate solution for a lot
of the big data problems.
And now enterprises
are realizing, like,
hey, that possibly
is not the solution.
We need to refocus on
modernizing the data warehouse
to handle scale and address the
modern business requirements
from the warehouse.
So as I was kind of
reflecting back, like,
what has been the evolution
of the data warehouse?
And data warehouse
is not a use case.
And David is going
to talk about how
they are using the
warehouse to do something
that was not possible
before, like application log
monitoring.
In '90s, when
possibly many of you
started working on
warehouse, may not
have started working that
time, operational reporting was
the core essence.
And the way it was designed
was for a few users will
run a specific set of
queries that were predefined
and optimized, and this will
be the best performant queries
running against the warehouse.
Then came the era of
2000 when enterprises
started realizing the
fact that customers
want to do ad hoc analysis.
They want to run
self-service BI.
Queries were not predefined.
And business users were
able to essentially create
queries on the fly.
And the kernel that was
supporting the warehouse
needed to essentially
optimize queries on the fly.
In the early 2010, I would
say the era of data mining
came in, where it was not
just good enough to look
at the business from retrospect
what is happening on my sales,
but why certain
things are happening.
So you will see a lot of
data warehouses started
adopting data mining
functions essentially.
Correlation, causality came in.
BigQuery.
We do support some of these.
And I'm going to talk about it.
And now as we stand
today, what is happening
with data warehouses
is businesses
are trying to get
predictive insights.
It's not just OK to look at
the data from retrospect.
It is important to
understand what's
going to happen to the
business based on the last X
number of years of
data or X days of data
that I have in my warehouse.
So the evolution is really
important to understand.
So if you are operating
against a traditional warehouse
and you just want to
move it to Google Cloud
to do the same set of
use cases, possibly you
will underserve your business,
because a lot of things
that were not possible in
the warehouse in the past
is possible today.
So I'm sure many of you have
already been using BigQuery.
Some of you are new.
BigQuery is our enterprise
data warehousing platform.
It's designed for
massive scalability.
We are seeing customers who are
using BigQuery for terabytes
of data processing
to customers who
are using for hundreds of
petabytes of data processing
using BigQuery.
It's highly encrypted, durable.
And on the right side, if you
see, some of the things that
are unique to BigQuery.
For example, it's serverless.
And in the Home
Depot example, we
will hear why serverless
is so important,
because we have decoupled system
engineering from data analysis.
If you are streaming data
into the BigQuery service,
you do not need to worry
about load balancing.
Like, hey, if I stream
data into the service,
is it going to impact
my query performance?
Is it going to impact
user experience?
Some of those automations have
been taken care of by Google.
Google BigQuery supports
real-time data analysis.
And this is extremely important,
because data warehouses were
designed for batch paradigm.
And the reason why it was
designed was when you load data
into the warehouse, the kernel
cannot simultaneously address
a lot of query requests
coming from multiple users.
That's why back
in the days when I
used to work as a data warehouse
person, load data on the night,
in the morning, 8:00
AM, fresh reports
were served to
management people,
that paradigm has
completely shifted.
Home Depot, for example, is
streaming data in real time
from multiple systems to
do analysis on that data.
King as an example here.
They're one of the largest
gaming companies, the makers
of the "Candy Crush Saga."
This essentially has streamed
billions of events in real time
into the warehouse every
hour and do analysis
on gaming telemetry.
ML is built into BigQuery.
BigQuery ML, you have heard
about the announcement.
We have gone beyond just
traditional regression.
We support now
[INAUDIBLE] clusterings,
matrix factorization, and
other algorithms for you
to do lot of
ML-related use cases.
And then we announced BI Engine.
And that's allowing customers
to do essentially concurrent
access on highly
accelerated data
sets for subsequent
queries on BI data sets.
So as I said, BigQuery
is serverless.
I'm not going to
spend much time.
I'm sure you have
seen versions of this.
Fundamentally,
BigQuery abstracts
a lot of the things on the gray
and the black that you see,
the monitoring, provisioning,
indexing, defragmentation.
Nothing is [INAUDIBLE].
You essentially put
the data in and you
start querying the data.
So this is at a
very high level what
BigQuery's architecture is.
If you are familiar,
you know this,
BigQuery has a decouple
storage and compute layer.
So essentially, when
you stream data in
or you bulk load the data
into the storage system,
the query engine can essentially
operate independently.
And it allows you to scale
those two things independently
of each other.
It has a streaming buffer.
So that allows you
to essentially use
BigQuery's stream API to insert
up to 100,000 rows per second.
We can essentially
increase those soft limits
if the requirement [? be. ?]
And then on the
right side, BigQuery
has a great programming
layer on top of it.
So if you want to
programmatically access
BigQuery data from
the applications
for further analysis,
that's possible.
So I wanted to kind of make
things real a little bit
and give you some
examples of how
the traditional mold
of data warehousing
has been broken
by many customers.
And these are some
of the examples.
One example that comes
to my mind is Zulily.
And they're an
e-commerce company.
They essentially stream in
up to 5 billion events a day
into BigQuery in real time.
And they use those
essentially user click events
on their website to do
personalized recommendations
for their product launches
that they do in their website.
So again, an example, customers
are doing real-time analytics
against their data warehouse.
The second example
is 20th Century Fox.
And 20th Century Fox
essentially is using BigQuery
to do predictive analytics.
They are doing user segmentation
for their new movie releases.
They're essentially bringing
in their marketing analysts
to do segmentation
using BigQuery ML
and then disseminating
their insights
with their organization.
And then AirAsia.
They have been one
of our key customers
for the BI Engine launch.
They were doing alpha
testing with us.
And AirAsia is
essentially storing
a lot of their important
data sets in BigQuery.
And now what they're
doing is they're
allowing their non-technical
business users, front line
users, to use Data Studio and
Sheets to connect with the data
and analyze that data.
So essentially, if
you think about,
again, traditional
enterprise data warehouse,
few users playing with the data
from that multiple user groups
are playing with the
same data simultaneously.
And there are many more
examples where customers
have done incredible job with
what's possible with the data
warehouse.
So it's time to
reimagine and see
something new that we haven't
talked in the past before.
And Home Depot team,
over the last year or so,
built a planet-scale
application monitoring
system using BigQuery.
So they're using their
core data warehouse
to do something that we
haven't seen in the past.
So I'd like to welcome
David from Home Depot
to share his experience.
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID NARAYAN: Thank you, Sap.
Hello.
It's good to be with
you this morning.
So last year at Next, a
couple of my colleagues
were here talking about how we
migrated our enterprise data
warehouse to BigQuery.
And that was a huge effort,
but it was a tremendous success
for our company.
So today I'd like to talk about
a completely different use
case for BigQuery.
It may be a little
bit nontraditional.
But I would like to
talk about how we're
using it for operational data.
But first, just a
little bit of background
about the Home Depot.
We're the world's largest
home improvement retailer.
We have about 2,300 stores
and about 150 supply
chain facilities across
the US, Canada, and Mexico.
While we're a retail
company, technology
is really at the center of
almost everything that we do.
We're investing a lot of energy
and money into technology.
And in fact, 90% of the software
that runs our retail operations
is developed in-house.
So with all of these sites
and systems and applications,
they're generating a lot
of operational telemetry.
So today I'm going to
talk about our efforts
to build a pipeline to
collect and analyze all
of that operational telemetry.
So what do I mean by
operational telemetry?
Often we think of that as
things like logs and metrics
and traces from
applications, which is true,
but we've expanded
that definition
to include things like
network flows, DNS queries,
logs from system and servers
and network appliances,
and also things like
associate systems,
like registers and mobile
devices, in our stores
and supply chain facilities.
So why collect all this data?
What's the point?
Well, a lot of this
data can be used
to help us understand
our environment,
or at least that's the
prevailing theory, right?
But we've really thought about
it in terms of three use cases.
So the first is the idea
of audit compliance.
A lot of the data we collect
because we simply have to.
We have to store the data
to meet our [INAUDIBLE]
or PCI or other
sorts of regulations.
The second reason
that we want this data
is for monitoring
and observability
or these traditional
use cases, where
we want to make sure that
our teams have the ability
to understand what's going
on in their environment.
And then the third, we
want to collect this data
and perform analysis on it
to derive longer-term trends,
do capacity planning,
give us a sense of what's
coming in the future.
So who benefits from this data?
Well, one of the principles
that we established early on
was that we wanted to
collect data once and allow
multiple teams to
access that same data.
It doesn't make sense to
recollect the same data over
and over again.
So we've identified
three teams that
really find value in the
data that we're collecting.
The first is our security
team, and it's not just
for audit compliance.
We also collect data for
threat detection and incident
response, so that they can
respond to things quickly.
The second team is our
application developers.
They use the data for
troubleshooting and diagnosing
their systems, their
applications, what's
going on in their environment.
And then the third would be our
infrastructure and operations
team.
They also use the data to
monitor their environment,
maybe from a
different perspective,
and also use it to think
about capacity planning,
longer-term trends, et cetera.
So a few years ago, our attempt
to build this particular system
looked a little bit like this.
So what we had was a set of
third party and open source
collectors that would collect
all kinds of different data,
ports and protocols
and things like that,
syslog, HTTP, et cetera.
Most of that raw data
fed our Kafka pipeline.
And then we would
take that raw data
and put it into Hadoop
for long-term storage
and feed it to a set of third
party log analysis tools
for real-time query and search.
Unfortunately, there were
a number of challenges
for this approach.
The biggest challenge was
the increasing data volume
that we were seeing
each and every day.
When we originally
built this system,
we were anticipating a few
terabytes of data per day.
But we quickly
exceeded that and were
moving into the tens and dozens
of terabytes of data per day.
And all of this data
had a significant impact
on our query performance.
Especially dense data,
like network flow traffic
or those sorts of things,
would take a really long time
to complete, hours
in some cases.
And of course, that was a
very frustrating experience
for our users.
Retention periods
was also a problem,
as the more data we
collected, we really
couldn't keep up and offer our
users the level of retention
they wanted.
In some cases, we were
only able to keep logs
for just a few days, which was
really frustrating for teams
that wanted to be able to do
comparative analysis, which
is really important in
a retail environment.
We're really interested in
looking at how today looks like
compared to last week or
maybe the same day last month
or even the same day last year.
And the limits we
had in our system
just made it impossible to
do those sorts of analysis.
And then, finally,
all this data meant
we had all this
infrastructure to deal with.
And all this
infrastructure meant
that we had lots of
problems and lots
of time spent dealing
with the infrastructure.
All of the time that
we were spending
dealing on infrastructure
was less time
that we were able to spend
taking care of our users,
improving their experience.
I know you've probably
heard the term data lake.
But when we built this system,
and all these challenges
that we were experiencing,
it felt a little bit more
like a data dumpster.
We were just dumping
all this data in,
and we were really unable
to derive any value from it.
So we decided it was
time for a new approach.
And so what we did was
we considered the problem
as four steps.
So the first step is
to collect the data.
All that raw data
that's floating around
in our environment, we
need a way to collect it.
And we had a pretty good
sense of how to do that.
The second step is to
transform that data.
We wanted to take
the raw data, turn it
into some sort of usable format.
It might be semi-structured.
It might be structured.
But somehow we needed
to make it usable.
The third step was we needed
to store the data somewhere.
Stick it somewhere that
we could reason with it,
interact with it, et cetera.
The last step is analyze.
And this is the one that's
really, really important.
Analyze is a word
that gets used a lot.
But really, it's just
the idea that you
want to be able to search and
interact and explore your data.
You want to have a conversation
with it, if you will.
And we really
wanted to make sure
that any system that we
decided on building, any system
that we developed, allowed our
users to have that conversation
with their data.
So like any good software
engineering problem,
we cut the problem in half.
And what we did was we
decided to keep our collection
and transformation
functions in-house,
which made sense,
because we had already
spent a lot of engineering
time working on that problem.
We had a lot of collectors
and aggregation tiers
in place to get the data.
And there are so many remote
sites and systems at Home Depot
that it didn't really make
sense for all the systems
to send straight to the cloud.
The transformation
layer also was something
that we started
to keep in-house,
because we needed to make sure
all the aggregation functions
were there and turn it into
some sort of structured data.
But the store and
analyze functions,
we felt like we could
move those to the cloud
and that would be a win for us.
And so we started looking
at ways to do that.
And we felt that
when we did that,
we would be able to optimize
cost and really improve
our resource efficiency.
If we were able
to move the store
and analyze functions
to the cloud,
we felt like our engineers could
spend a lot more time focused
on getting the
data in and making
it valuable to our
users and less time
on dealing with the
infrastructure itself.
Plus, if we were able to use
a managed service for storing
and analyzing data,
we felt like we
would be able to really
take advantage of the scale
and elasticity of the cloud.
So these are sort
of the guidelines
that we were considering as we
were looking at a new approach
here.
And so we started our
evaluation process
with a number of
different considerations.
So the first is, what are
the features of the platform
that we're interested in?
And first and
foremost, we needed
to make sure that it was
going to handle our scale.
We wanted to make
sure that it was
going to start with
the tens of terabytes
that we were getting right
when we started, but was going
to be able to grow with us
for all the volume and all
the variety of data
that we collect.
We have hundreds of
different data types
that we're pulling
in the system.
We needed to make sure that
it was capable of handling
all of that data.
And we needed to
make sure that it had
multiple modes of ingestion.
We often have cases where we
need to backfill data or bulk
load data or put data
into the system in lots
of different ways.
We also have cases where we
need to stream it in real time
and our users need immediate
access to that data.
So it was really important
that whatever system we picked
had different ways of getting
that data into the system.
The second thing we
considered was how well it
integrated with other systems.
It was important for our
users to have a fairly shallow
learning curve if we adopted
a whole new system that they
were going to interact with.
And so we wanted something that
was at least familiar with them
and didn't require a
lot of upfront learning.
And secondly, we
wanted to make sure
that our users could
bring their own tools
to the data for analytics.
That might be anything
from a spreadsheet
to BI tools to code.
We wanted to make sure
that they had those options
available to them.
And then, of course, the
third thing was security.
As we were moving to
a managed service,
it was obviously
very important for us
to ensure that data to
and from that system
was encrypted and
secure, and it was
being stored in the same way.
And of course, we
wanted to make sure
that our data was able
to be segmented up.
Because we had these
different teams
of users that need
access that data,
we wanted to make sure that we
could authorize different users
to different
segments of the data,
and make sure we could
split it up easily.
And then, of course, finally,
with a managed service,
we wanted to make sure it
reduces costs and improves
efficiencies.
And that's the idea behind
a fully managed service.
We wanted to ensure that we
had a fully managed service
and it wasn't
something that we're
going to have to tinker with
or babysit or watch over.
And of course, as
a managed service,
we wanted to make sure that
it wasn't so narrow in focus
that we could only use
it for a few use cases.
We wanted to make sure that it
covered as many as possible.
It might surprise you to
learn that BigQuery was not,
in fact, the first option
that we considered.
We actually spent a
significant amount
of time evaluating
lots of options.
And being in the operational
telemetry and log collection
space, we started
with a lot of services
that are in that space,
log collection services.
As it turned out,
BigQuery was really
the only one that met all
of these considerations.
And so we felt pretty
confident in its ability
to cover all these use cases.
And we felt like we
could move forward
with BigQuery as
a managed service,
as its ability to put
vast amounts of data
without falling over.
And we also felt confident
that we'd be able to partner
with Google to discuss
and cover any challenges
that we might expect.
So this is what we
ended up building.
And this system is actually
in production right now.
It's been in production
for about a year.
What we ended up doing was
we kept our collection tier
on-prem, same data
systems going into Kafka.
We replaced the
third-party code that we
had doing transformations
with some new code
that we built in-house.
And what it does is it
takes all of that raw data
and it turns it into
structured data using
Avro serialization, which
is something that BigQuery
understands natively.
All of those serialized
files are then
uploaded to Cloud
Storage, and then we
use the BigQuery batch loading
API to load the data every 20
seconds into BigQuery.
One of the reasons that we
wanted to use structured data
here is that it
gives us the ability
to separate out our data sets.
The challenge of the old
system was all the data
was in this data
dumpster and it was
very difficult to find the
data you're looking for.
Once we were able to transform
the data into structured data
sets, users could go
right to the table
that they were interested in to
start querying and interacting
with their data.
So as I mentioned, this
particular system's
been in place for about a
year and we are already seeing
some pretty significant wins.
The first, of course,
is data volume.
And we're easily able to put
tens of terabytes of data
into the system
each and every day.
And we're confident
that we'll be
able to put more and more
data as it needs to go.
The second is query performance.
As we said earlier, our
enterprise data warehouse team
was already using BigQuery.
And so when we
selected BigQuery,
we were able to take advantage
of some organizational
economies of scale.
One of the ways that we get
the scale from BigQuery is we
had these things called query
slots, which is basically
like a fixed Compute Engine.
The more query slots
you have, the faster
performance on BigQuery.
And because the
enterprise data warehouse
is running on BigQuery and
all of our operational data's
on BigQuery, both teams
were able to take advantage
of that pool of query slots,
so that whether you're
querying for operational
data or if you're
querying for
enterprise data, you
get to take advantage of
the extra performance that's
afforded to each
of the data sets.
So that was a huge win for us.
After we had moved a lot of
our data sets over to BigQuery,
one of my engineers was working
on a problem with some network
data.
And he wanted some help
translating his query
from the old system
over to the new system.
And this was a query that
was looking at, like,
30 days of network traffic.
So it was a fairly
large data set.
And it was looking at
traffic to and from
a particular organization that
had maybe 60 or 70 different
[INAUDIBLE].
So kind of a complicated query.
I'm not that great at SQL, but
I said I'll take a look at it
and see if I can make it work.
So I sat down and tinkered
with it for a little bit.
And I got something running,
at least in the system,
and it seemed to sort of
meet the needs of what
he was looking for.
But it was running in
about maybe five minutes.
I didn't know what
his expectations were.
So I went back to him.
I said, hey, I've
worked on your query.
I think it's working.
It's taking about
five minutes to run.
So if you want it
to run faster, we
should probably get someone else
involved who's better at SQL
than me.
And he said, five minutes?
Are you sure?
I said, yeah, I'm sure.
You can come look at it.
I said, why?
How long was it taking
in the last system?
His response?
Five hours.
So with BigQuery,
the retention period
is another big win for us.
Retention period in BigQuery
is really just a setting.
It's not months of
infrastructure planning
or hardware build,
at least not for us.
Maybe on the Google side it is.
But from our perspective, it's
just a setting on the table.
And so, by default, we're able
to offer 90 days, by default,
for all of our
customer data sets.
And for some data sets,
like security data sets,
we keep for years.
And so all of the data
sets that we had before,
which were only
available for a few days,
now our teams are able to
do that comparative analysis
that they were asking for.
So that's been a
huge win for us.
And infrastructure maintenance.
By moving to
BigQuery, we have been
able to eliminate 10 petabytes
of Hadoop infrastructure, which
was a really big win for us.
So a few observations
now that this system
has been running in
production for about a year.
So I mentioned some
of the custom code
that we were writing.
We tried really
hard to stick with
third-party and open-source
code for as long as possible.
Writing these custom codes takes
longer than you think it will.
It always kind of runs.
You run into a lot of
unexpected problems
more frequently than
you think you will.
And so we tried really hard
to stick with that custom code
for as long as possible and
only write our own custom
code when we really had to.
The second thing is, use
managed services where possible.
With BigQuery, there's a
whole class of problems
that I don't have
to think about.
How data's stored,
how it's replicated,
all the search and
query performance
and the engineering
behind that, that's
all something that the Google
team gets to worry about.
I get to just take advantage
of that architecture.
And so it's now easy for us to
load tens of terabytes a day.
The data retention is simply
a setting for a table.
And our query performance
is from hours and days
down to seconds and minutes.
All of these things
are really good.
But even in our current
system, there are some things
that we want to improve.
The first thing is that
we experience some delays
in data availability.
I mentioned this is
for operational data.
Operational data is
like a fire hose.
It never, ever stops.
And so if there's any
problem in our pipeline, what
tends to happen
is the recent data
gets stuck behind all of the
data that was in before it.
And so we get this
backlog of data,
where users are sort of
twiddling their thumbs,
waiting on their data.
It's not a very good
experience for them.
Also, on one of
Sap's earlier slides,
there's a comment that says
free bulk loading, which
is true up to a point.
When you're loading
this much data,
you actually have to get these
things called load slots, which
are these sort of
compute units that
allow you to load
lots and lots of data
into BigQuery in batch mode.
As it turns out,
these load slots
are a little bit
difficult to predict.
We have this huge
fire hose of data.
So any sort of burst in data
can be difficult to predict
and it can be tough to
make sure that we're not
going to have an
operational impact when we
have that giant burst of data.
Also, and somewhat
unfortunately, load slots
are incompatible
with query slots.
So we were put in the
sort of awkward position
of trying to spend resources
on either load slots or query
slots and improving load times
or improving query times.
So that was something
that we wanted
to address on the next
evolution of this architecture.
The other thing
that we experienced
was a lot of quotas and
resource limits and things
that we ran into.
As we started
building the system,
we would run into one
quota, work with the team
to get it adjusted, and then run
head first into the next one.
So there's a lot
of things that need
to be tuned and adjusted
to deal with the scale
and volume of data that
we were interested in.
We also weren't
nearly creative enough
thinking about the
types of failures
that we might run into
building the system.
One good example
is that we started
with using regional buckets
on cloud storage for all
of those Avro files.
One regional outage
taught us to quickly move
to multi-regional storage.
The second thing is to really
think about fault domains.
One mistake we made
building the system was we
built essentially
one giant pipeline.
That was a mistake, because
any impact in the system
impacted all of our customers.
So one of the things
that we're working on
is splitting that up into
smaller fault domains
to limit the number of
people that are mad at us
at any given time.
So the design for the new
system is actually already done.
And it's in testing right now.
And the plan is to move to
it in the next few months.
So this is what our next phase
of the architecture looks like.
We're essentially moving
more to a streaming model.
One of the things that
we did was that we
rewrote our collection tier.
We had all this third-party
and open-source tools
that we were using, and it
was becoming more complicated
and more difficult to manage.
So we wrote our own
collection tier,
which gave us the
ability to classify data
as it was being streamed in.
And that way we were able
to separate this data out
as it feeds into
Kafka, and then we
could upload that data
already classified up
into Cloud Storage.
That gave us a single
ingestion tier to worry about.
And we were able to
get consistent stats
and performance across
the entire tier.
From there, the process
is very similar.
All of the data that
goes into Cloud Storage,
it is already in
those Avro files
that I talked about earlier.
But once the file is created,
we generate a notification
that goes into Pub/Sub.
Our transformation tier is now
running on Kubernetes Engine.
And so it's just using
a pull subscription
to listen for those
notifications.
Once it gets one,
it reads the file
from Cloud Storage that
streams the data into BigQuery.
Some of the advantages
of this new system.
We're getting much
faster data availability
with BigQuery streaming than
we were with the batch loads.
In some cases, data is now
available in seconds as opposed
to minutes.
Because we've moved a lot of our
transform workload over to GKE,
we're now able to take
advantage of things
like Kubernetes pod
autoscaling to grow and shrink
our compute resources
over the course of a day.
And this particular model
addresses the problem
of the last model, which
was the data getting
stuck behind that older data.
So how does that work?
Let me dive into that
for just a second.
So the way this works is we
built essentially two paths
for these notifications.
And the notifications only
use one path at a time.
So as the data is streamed up
and written into Cloud Storage,
we generate those notifications
on either the A path or the B
path.
If one path starts
getting behind or there's
a backlog or any
sort of problem,
just like a railroad switch, we
just switch the notifications
to the secondary
path, and from there,
all the recent data can
be streamed into BigQuery,
and the backlog data
can just flow in
as it was flowing in before.
But this gives us
the opportunity
to keep recent data recent
and available for our users.
So a few lessons learned
from our experience
building this system.
The first thing
is, keep it simple.
There's a lot of complexity
in the system already.
There's a lot of
options out there,
a lot of tools and things to
play with and tinker with.
But we only started
with two cloud services
when we built this system,
Cloud Storage and BigQuery,
that was it.
And we didn't move forward with
any additional cloud services
until we felt like we
had really understood
those services and the impact
that those services was going
to have on the overall system.
All of the additional complexity
that you add to the system
means that your failures are
going to be more complex.
It's more your
team has to learn.
So it's really important
to keep it simple.
Using those fault domains
to limit the impact
is another good lesson for us.
Simplicity in how many
things can go wrong
limit the overall
impact to the system
when something does
inevitably go wrong.
The second thing is, make
sure you iterate your design.
You've seen a couple
of different evolutions
of our architecture and what
we're about to implement.
And I'm sure there'll be
changes down the road as well.
You want to plan for
failures in your system.
It's not going to be
perfect from day one.
We certainly learned that.
We want to use those failures
to help iterate our design
and make those
incremental improvements.
A lot of the quotas and limits
and stuff that we ran into,
a lot of those can be adjusted.
So it's important to stay
aligned with your customer
engineering team to make sure
that you kind of stay ahead
of those particular limits.
And then consider your
workload placement over time.
It doesn't have to be the
case that all of your workload
moves to the cloud from day one.
We certainly didn't.
We started with a hybrid model.
We're continuing
with a hybrid model.
We have a lot of workload
that runs on-prem.
We're moving different
pieces to the cloud
as it fits our
particular use case.
And you should feel free
to do the same thing.
That is a good
model to work with.
And lastly, focus on value.
And what I mean
by this is really
think more about
outcomes and what
you're trying to get
to for your customers
than the engineering effort.
A lot of times we get excited by
the engineering, and that's OK.
There's a lot of fun
toys to play with here.
But it's important to really
think about the outcome of what
you're trying to get to.
When you're using something like
BigQuery as a managed service,
it's important to realize
that there's a lot of things
you don't have to worry about.
You can immediately start
having that conversation
with your data, and
your users will benefit.
And then, of course,
think about ways
to cut the problem in half,
to leverage your partners,
and to make sure that you're
able to continue to use them
as sort of an extension
of your engineering team
as you focus on those outcomes.
So that's really it.
My team has certainly learned
a lot building this system.
And hopefully, some
of these experiences
will be helpful
for you if you're
considering something similar.
[MUSIC PLAYING]